I want once and for all for you to tell
me how big a deal is the threat of China
into our digital world oh gosh that's a
that's a complicated question I what I
would say is in terms of cyber espionage
I think we are I think we are the
Muhammad Ali of of this form of warfare
I I'm incredibly confident based on the
company's I see and the government
officials idea what strike me is
exceptionally competent that anybody
wants to step into the ring with us on
to fight around cyber espionage it's
going to walk away bloody you know
there's another angle to this which is
the entire history from the first
industrial revolution on of countries
catching up to the technological
frontier has begun by stealing
intellectual property we did it to the
Brits then upon the Japanese and Koreans
did it to us now China's doing it to
everybody the difference here though and
this is significant this is not if you
like free market theft of intellectual
property this is a very large scale
quite well coordinated targeted and
focused national policy that's what
makes it politically problematic and why
it won't go away